créée en 92 le musée de la résistance et
de la déportation va fermer ses portes
fin 2019 pour une rénovation devenu
nécessaire nouvelle gestion de l'espace
scénographie remise au goût du jour et
découverte de collection depuis 1990 on
a eu des nouvelles acquisitions des
nouveaux objets qui sont rentrés dans
les archives dans les collections et qui
ne peuvent pas être actuellement montrer
au public puisque le musée n'a pas la
place nécessaire ne parcourt ne le
permettent à la collection germaine
tillon est très attendu comme ces objets
recherchés par le musée autour de la
résistance et de la déportation autour
de la réaliser en camp par les déportés
parce qu'on aimerait particulièrement à
voir ce sont des dessins d'art
concentrationnaire qui sont vraiment le
clou de la collection du musée qui vont
être affichés par la suite en dans le
nouveau musée
cette mémoire précieuse a besoin de
nouveaux souffles de relais et de
musicalité aussi comme le rappelle sarah
lecarpentier venu présenter aux ma
mémoire la poésie ma nécessité d'après
stéphane hessel son grand-père à
l'invitation du musée
cet espace a forcément une résonance
toute particulière à c'est aussi une
invitation à se souvenir à avoir envie
de lire de la poésie à avoir envie de
leur faire mémoire collective vous dont
la bouche est fait à l'image de celle de
dieu bush qui l ordre même soyez
indulgents quand vous nous comparez à
ceux qui furent la perfection de l'ordre
nous quittons partout de l'aventuré on
retrouve toute sa biographie à lui y
compris bien sûr politiques historiques
les moments où il a résisté et est
déportée puis après dans sa carrière
diplomatique mais c'est pas vu sous
l'angle du personnage public ou de la
politique s'est vu en poésie nous
voulons explorer la bonté contre est
énorme
tous étaient accompagnés par simon baril
est sarah lecarpentier transmet la
mémoire de stéphane hessel
à travers cette poésie qu'il a tenus
debout